just finding it and how's that yes
that's perfect you just stay right there
this is poor Donna you're the one that
wanted me to draw your portrait like
what do you think this was gonna be like
I thought it might be like a little fun
okay well just hold it still okay okay
you are my nipples hurry capturing that
that's a card with overalls but I wanna
seriously Oh
oh yeah yeah here we go wanna have you
ever heard of continuity okay have you
ever heard of a bitch's hair was in her
eyes am I supposed to be naked for this
the answer now and forever is no you
should not be naked okay listen you
watch your tone of delivery bitch I'm
sorry okay I'm done okay I'm so excited
to see you okay I hope you like it dude
oh my taita
it's aspirational for my nipples - thank
you I love it